alright guys so i wanted to make a
deep-diving video about the major red
flag surrounding sos
and why you should be cautious before
investing into the company
but i just learned about some major news
so i decided to cut the video short
first of all hindenburg research is
currently looking into sos limited
these are the people who called out
nikola motors causing their stock to
crash nearly 75
but even more importantly one of my
friends noticed a massive change in the
short interest
for sos as of february 23 2021
10 million shares of sos were available
to short this morning however
this number plunged to just 3.6 million
shares
meaning that 6.4 million shares were
shorter between yesterday
and today this could be a lot of retail
investors getting in
but retailers generally don't short
companies they usually buy puts
moreover sos limited currently trades
for about eight dollars per share
so in order to short 6.4 million shares
you would need 51.2
million dollars also broker just won't
let you short 51.2 million
worth of shares if you just have 51.2
million
if the trade goes against you brokerages
don't want to be held liable
so they'll usually require short sellers
to have 150
to 200 percent of the value they're
shorting especially with volatile stocks
like
sos this means that to short 6.4 million
shares of sos
75 to 100 million worth of capital was
required
on top of this the fee to borrow these
shares is about 50
meaning that sos limited would have to
crash quite heavily for these short
sellers to profit
in the first place with that being said
it's very likely that some big player
has significant evidence against sos
and that's why they're shorting so
heavily so please be extremely careful
with
sos and in the meantime here's some of
the evidence that has been collected
so far before we get into it though i
wanted to thank all the people who
gathered all of this evidence in the
belmont discord
especially mike m brought by stealth
scotty b
and many many more anyways the first
piece of evidence is that all the news
that has come out about sos
is from sos themselves if you go onto
their website
you can find a new center tab and this
is where all the news about the company
comes out
not a single third-party media agency
has written their own report about the
company
for instance pr newswire is a publisher
relaying sos limited news
and if you look closely at each of their
publications you'll see that the news
was provided by sos limited
similarly on each yahoo finance article
about sos
the only source they cite authentic
article is sos themselves
as a result we don't have any evidence
as to whether their claims are credible
in the first place number two sos is
doing business with some extremely
shitty businesses
including a company called fxk and
another company called hy international
on january 19th 2021 sos limited
announced that they had entered a
non-binary letter of intent to acquire
affects k-tech corporation
fxk is apparently a canadian-based
blockchain technology company
who is going to help sos with their
mining operation but
here's the thing fxk's website is a
direct rip-off of a real mining company
called
rhy you can put these two websites side
by side
and you'll see that they're identical
across the board
nearly everything is exactly the same
except for one key difference
you can actually buy mining equipment
from rhi mining as they have a buy
button
under the listings meanwhile fxk does
not have a buy button
under the listings so you can't actually
buy any mining equipment from them
something that's much more concerning is
if we go into source code of fxk's
website
we can see several patches of chinese
characters now remember
fxk is supposedly a canadian company and
they have not yet been acquired by
sos in fact the agreement they signed
with sos is not even binding
so there shouldn't be any relation
between the two companies yet and we
shouldn't see chinese characters in the
source code
another major red flag with fxk is that
if we look at their contact info
we'll see that their email address is
fxk fxkltd outlook.com
if we enter this email into outlook and
press the forgot password button
we can see that the recovery email is
under the domain 163.com
and guess what 163.com is a chinese
email provider evidently
fxk seems to have major links to china
even though it is apparently a canadian
company
on top of this if we search for sos and
fxk source code
we find 35 matches if we take a closer
look
we'll see that this is because every
single one of the images on fxk's
website
is under the name sos bx which is sos
limited's insurance company
again sos has not actually bought fxk
yet
furthermore if we do some more digging
into fxk
we see that they were incorporated on
july 8 2020 with the following address
if we look that up on google maps you'll
see that the address is just a suburban
house
now many startups do start in people's
houses but i highly doubt that a mining
equipment company that's working with
sos limited to generate 200
000 per day is being run out of a garage
so that's fxk now let's take a look at
the other company sos is working with
hy international first of all h1
international seems to be a direct
ripoff of
rhy mining they literally just dropped h
anyways on january 21st 2021 sos
announced that they were buying 15
645 mining rigs from h1 international
so clearly h4 international must be a
major mining equipment supplier
however if we go look at their contact
information the primary contact of a
major mining equipment supplier
is their ceo claire lowe now that's odd
in itself and i don't think that's his
real name
but maybe he's a super dedicated ceo
looking to address all of his customers
concerns
himself however here's where things get
super sketchy
once again if you go under their product
and services tab
you'll see that they have a couple of
mining rigs listed if you go under these
listings though
you once again cannot purchase a single
one of them this makes absolutely no
sense what type of legitimate company
doesn't allow customers to buy products
from their official website
but to give hr international the benefit
of the doubt the people running belmont
capital decided to call up customer
support to see if they could buy any
mining equipment
they posed as a random customer and
asked the ceo if they could buy some
mining rigs
i think you won't be surprised to hear
that the request was rejected
again why would they reject potential
revenue
i have no clue
it doesn't just stop right here either
sos also has links to a company called e
secure chain
on january 6 2001 as it was announced
they were hiring dr eric wazong yen
who is apparently an expert in
cryptocurrency mining security and
insurance technology
before he joined sos though he was the
founder of a company called esecurechain
which sos even acknowledges
e-securechain has a very similar website
layout to sosyon.com
but here's what's even more important if
we go onto wayback machine which is a
way to look at how websites used to look
we'll see that e-secure chain has no
history before february 18th 2021
in fact this is the same case with hy
international as well
fxk on the other hand does have history
but the historic page simply tells you
in chinese that the domain
is available for sale so none of these
three websites even existed just a
couple of weeks ago
and here's a nail in the coffin fxk
h4 international and e-secure chain are
all run from the same
ip address alright so this is how far i
got into the script
until i learned about the massive shorts
and potential hindenburg report
there's so many more sketchy things
about the company like a plethora of
direct offerings
a shitty past and much much more but
i want to get this video out as soon as
possible so i'm not going to cover
anything else
if you guys are interested in more
information please check out belmont
capitals videos on it
i've linked his channel in the
description also be sure to check out tj
investing's youtube channel
he's going to be covering more news
about sos very soon
in the end i'm not 100 sure if sos
is a fraud and this is not financial
advice
however there are extremely big red
flags with the company
and big money is trying to bet against
it so
it's much safer to sell your stake if
you have one instead
if you want to invest in crypto mining
companies look into riot and
mara anyways drop a like if you guys
appreciate the heads up
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one